crónico dolores musculares e intensas
migrañas la endometriosis hace que la
vida de jazmina sea particularmente
difícil y con tan solo 42 años anhela
una vida normal
Esta es mi casa la he comprado para
vivir sola pero debido a las
limitaciones que me provoca la
endometriosis no no lo puedo hacer
Necesito ayuda para que me hagan la
comida muchas veces me tienen que llevar
a la cama
sería imposible para yasmina vivir sin
la ayuda de su madre diagnosticada hace
dos años Ahora tiene que tomar unos 20
medicamentos y suplementos alimenticios
a diario curso pasado Yo Soy maestra
estuve como 10 meses de baja y menos mal
que trabajo en una escuela pública si no
hubiese perdido mi trabajo seguro en
España era a partir de ahora permisos
menstruales a las mujeres cuando los
médicos lo consideren necesario y serán
financiados al 100% por el estado el
ayuntamiento de Girona en el noreste ya
ofrecía un plan similar desde hace un
año y medio 600 trabajadoras pueden
solicitar tiempo libre por periodos
dolorosos
Bueno a mirar los datos de llevamos el
tema de la menstruación lo han pedido
así de mujeres en total en todo el
ayuntamiento las mujeres pueden tomarse
hasta ocho horas al mes siempre y cuando
recuperen el tiempo y no tienen que
proporcionar ninguna incapacidad un
éxito para aquellas personas que
realmente lo necesitan no es un número
muy elevado pero sí que es un derecho
que sabe que dispone todas las
trabajadoras los representantes
sindicales solicitaron la licencia este
portavoz cree que la ley nacional va más
allá todavía siendo España pionera en
Europa
es un avance en el Sí porque pone la
menstruación en el en Boca de la
sociedad y porque reconoce patologías
relacionadas con la menstruación en un
país donde alrededor del 15% de las
mujeres sufre de endometriosis